well fraud is at an all-time high in the
AARP fraud watch Network keeps track of
the latest scams and tactics and tonight
see it on your side we
took their fraud experience
a new AARP fraud watch Network survey
shows the majority of Americans believe
fraud has hit a crisis level according
to the FTC last year two and a half
million scams were reported but
criminals stole nine billion dollars in
2022 Nevada saw 110 million dollars in
fraud losses but that's just what's
reported and we know it's severely
underreported Kathy Stokes is a director
of fraud prevention programs at AARP
criminals know that the best way to get
a Target to become a victim is to get
them into a heightened emotional state
if you suspect someone is a scammer
disengaged from them paying up the phone
Stokes as consumers are becoming more
Savvy to the tactics used by scammers
for instance the survey revealed 75
percent of Americans say they know
anytime they're asked to pay an
obligation with a gift card it's a scam
now while they may know this Stoke says
people are still falling victim to the
gift card scam the data show that 228
million dollars were lost to these scams
last year so we still have some more
work to do there the more people hear
about scams the less likely they are to
engage in them but part of the problem
Stoke says is getting the word out and
making sure people recognize that scams
are a financial crime she adds we have a
tendency in our society to use language
that blames the victim for having
experienced fraud which may deter
someone from reporting it we say they
were duped or they fell for it or say
how much money did you give them instead
of you know trying to build them up and
say look this wasn't your fault I'm so
sorry this happened to you let's figure
out what to do the AARP fraud watch
network is a free resource for all ages
simply sign up for weekly Watchdog
alerts by email or text at aarp.org
forward slash fraud watch Network you
will learn how to proactively spot scams
and get guidance from Specialists if
you've been targeted